[Music]
so
[Music]
coming up on your weekly news show a
drought is officially declared in some
parts of the country but what does that
actually mean
[Music]
plus life after britain's got talent we
catch up with anisha the climate change
poet who wowed the judges and all the
rest of us
hi fyi if there's ever a time to save
this planet it's now but how do we
spread this message
to others including adults i think i may
have cracked it
welcome to fyi now check out what we've
just found so this is westminster before
and this is after i mean just look at
the difference
look at how some of our country's most
famous landmarks have been scorched by
the heat waves we've been having it's
been the driest first six months of the
year since 1976
plus record-breaking temperatures and
this is how the uk looks from space now
i mean just look at that you can see
where those record temperatures and lack
of rainfall have hit hard
and it's those really dry areas of
england the experts say are now
officially experiencing a drought well
that got us thinking didn't it maya yeah
what does that actually mean a drought
is usually something you hear about in
hot countries in africa not england no
so right hear us out we've been digging
up the info
so these are the areas of the uk where
there is officially a drought and there
could be more areas in the coming weeks
even though it has rain recently in many
areas it's just nowhere near enough to
fill up our reservoirs that provide
water to millions of people
so when an area is officially
experiencing a drought it means the
government and water companies need to
bring in rules to stop us using as much
water such as hose pipe bands more water
than usual could also be taken from
rivers
members of fy news clubs from across the
uk have been sending in their own ideas
of how we can save water
first of all remember to keep your
sprinklers off to conserve water
and second of all for the indoors always
fill up your dishwasher and washing
machine to the brim to make sure that
they're more efficient my first tip to
save water
is to have five-minute shelves instead
of long long baths
and my second tip is to turn off the tap
when you're brushing your teeth
reuse your towels instead of constantly
washing them after every shower
and number two make sure you turn your
taps off tightly preventing any chances
of dripping water a way we can recycle
our water is by using a washing up bowl
in the sink whilst we're washing our
dirty plates and forks and spoons and
then we can use that water again to
water our plants that way we don't have
to waste our water and our plants can
stay hydrated as well as us
good ideas there i think collecting
rainwater would be a good one you know
with the barrels i mean it's a little
bit difficult but you know it's a
suggestion or maybe it's something
simpler just having shorter showers
meanwhile half of europe is affected by
huge forest fires
severe temperatures and little rainfall
have made the forest so dry that
firefighters across france spain germany
and other countries are battling to keep
huge fires under control we don't have
to tell you guys that this extreme
weather is down to climate change
scientists are warning us that heat
waves will be more common if we don't
stop polluting our atmosphere with gases
that lead to climate change here on fyi
we'll be checking out the latest news on
climate change we'll be meeting the
campaigners making a stand checking out
new technology to beat global warming
and putting those with the power to make
real change on the spot we're going to
start with anish war remember him
hello he's the seven year old climate
activist that uses poetry to get his
message across his performance on
britain's got talent wowed the judges
and he's still at it talking about how
we can save our planet in any way we can
here's some of his top tips from his
back garden just for fyi
[Music]
the gorgeous peacocks stand stairway
fantastic golden eagles gliding display
because there's no other planet like
earth
when i went to bring got talent i was
overwhelmed like it felt really amazing
i couldn't believe it like
thank you everyone
and do you know why i care about this
nature so much
it's because
every animal has its own superpower like
our tiny ants
scuttle around and literally two of them
can lift an apple
my inspirational spot
is near my giant pond it is filled with
life that's why this garden the whole of
it is my square of inspiration
is the grassland habitat
be very slow over here excuse me bees
but these
bees aren't the best pollinators on the
planet
my pond is filled with life you can tell
because it's like even just looking
is that green color
because there's lots of algae
and algae is a great food source for
many creatures
you know all your food waste don't put
them in the black bin the black win is
for just throwing away if you put them
in the green bin or just dig in a hole
and putting them in your garden then
covering them that can be a fertilizer
it can help all this soil and that's
what sometimes we do
let's protect this planet we all adore
and keep it safe forevermore
anyone can report on fyi this is your
show all you have to do is send us
details about the story you want to tell
it can be about you an issue you want to
report on or even an event you want to
tell us about even better get your
teacher to set up an fyi news club at
your school every club has a chance to
take part in the program
for more details head to our webpage
first dot news fyi
[Music]
now if you don't like spiders look away
so what do you make of claims that
scientists have made dead spiders into
mini robots fake or fact
well it's fact
scientists turn dead wolf spiders into
mini grippers by taking control of their
bodies with a mechanical rig they could
be used to get a grip on small objects
in tight spaces for info on how to tell
if a story is fake or fat head to sky
kids on demand or our webpage and check
out our i don't get it explainer on how
to spot fake news
many pupils are beginning to receive
their gcse results in fact my sisters
are on their way at the minute but is it
too soon to be tested in an exam
they're the first gcse exam since
covering 19 emerged in 2019 we found a
survey that saves nine in ten teachers
fear that students will not get the
grades they deserve
even though teachers are marking our
exam papers generously you know taking
into account that many of us are behind
on school work we've been thinking is it
fair to bring back exams here's the
members of an fyi news club at southgate
school in london and what they think
pupils in england are going to be given
advanced notice of exam topics and their
answers will be marked more leniently
this year i think it's further gcses
have been graded more generously because
of covid's a lot of people missed out
like a learning in knockdown i think
they should do it for the next couple of
years
people have like missed out and i know
some people definitely didn't attend the
online lessons if there was additional
support given to gcse students i think
exams wouldn't have really been needed
to be generously graded it's hoped that
the changes will be fairer to teenagers
who have missed school during the
pandemic i do think that we would it
would be better if we received more
guidance what to advise for our gcse's
because it would help us develop kids
don't know how to revise and they just
think
reading over their notes and reading
like a textbook will help when it
actually doesn't i think in my opinion
we should be graded like not only for
exams but also like the whole year
because you might do well the whole year
and then the day of the exam you just
have a bad day yeah like in class you
might be really good at history but when
you're doing like a history exam or test
because you're stressed it might not be
as well as you wanted it to be so yeah i
can't think of a better way to be
assessed i'll be honest i feel like
seeing how students have progressed
throughout the years really shows their
academic ability in a better way than
just an exam written exam i agree but i
think perhaps a combination of both
would be the best
i think it's fair to say that school is
still a bit tough for many of us after
the pandemic so we got a hold of levan
for some advice hey laverne hi there so
what would your advice be if you didn't
get the exam results you expected
gosh well i suppose the first thing i'd
say is take a deep breath you know
setbacks happen but plans can be put in
place to help you manage things try and
be a bit kind to yourself focus on the
things that you can change and try not
to dwell on the things that you can't
change that's really good advice so
new schools new experiences new year
group how would you suggest we deal with
all these pressures you know the
opportunity to make new friendships is
really really important
having some worries about that is often
quite ordinary you know you might want
to be
checking out with friends and seeing how
they're feeling so that you don't get
too caught up and think that it's only
you that have got these worries i think
it's also very helpful to talk to
other friends or your parents or your
siblings and see how they've managed
these sorts of challenges thanks for the
advice laverne bye bye
and for more context of where to get
support head to our webpage first dot
news slash fyi
has someone ever said something
upsetting to you but they didn't intend
to insult you
or have you ever judged somebody based
on their appearance and got them totally
wrong well it's called unconscious bias
i know we don't get it either so we got
fy scarlett to investigate a phrase
that's been doing the rounds and check
this out she even got her own quiz show
it's time to play guess their job
hello everybody and welcome to the game
show that you can play from home
we've got four people for you to check
out and they're all real people with
real jobs and all you need to do is
figure out which important job they do
okay so the six options are cleaner
astronauts taxi driver
scientist
teacher or nurse
so let's start off with person a what
job do you think she does
well
she's a
driver if you got that right then give
yourself one point
next up is person b
could she be a cleaner an astronaut
scientist teacher or nurse
okay so the answer is
she's a scientist
in fact this is dr uslam terezi who
invented the first covert vaccine
one point if you got that right
question three can you figure out which
of the four remaining jobs this man does
well his name is stuart tuckwood
he's from liverpool
and his job is
a nurse
finally is this woman a cleaner an
astronaut or a teacher
well her name is nora al-matrushi she's
from the united arab emirates and her
job is
an astronaut
if you've got all four correct then
congratulations give yourself a huge
round of applause but if you didn't get
them all right then don't worry
the fact is that all of us make
judgments about people before we really
know them
just because of how they look the way
they speak
or whether they're a boy or a girl
it's called unconscious bias and
recently there's been a lot of headlines
about it
at first i didn't understand what it
meant but it turns out that we can all
be guilty of quickly forming unfair
opinions about certain types of people
and we're not even aware that we're
doing it
but why does it matter we're only human
right
let's get an expert's opinion on this
i've got a hold of dr doynatorwoligan
from the university of oxford she's a
psychologist who has helped loads of top
companies make sure that they're being
fair when hiring people
hi dr doyan hi scarlett
so is unconscious buyer something that
we should be worried about it is
scarlett absolutely
the thing is if you label someone as not
the sort of person you want to be
friends with or
not quite suitable for a job
just because of the way they look or
because of their accent
then that isn't fair and it could be
limiting their opportunities and
actually if you do this in a way
consistently
that has a negative impact on a group of
people because of a particular
characteristic that they have such as
their gender or their race or their
disability
that could be what we refer to as
discrimination and is illegal
so what can we do to make sure that our
unconscious bias doesn't lead to us
being unfair about people
that's a really great question scarlett
you've probably heard the expression
don't judge a book by its cover
and in essence that's the answer
thank you dr dwyane that's great advice
great scarlett
so the important thing we all need to
remember is to be open-minded about the
people we meet
to not make assumptions about them and
what they're capable of
and to look below the surface to find
out more about them
got it
for more i don't get to explain us on
just about everything head to sky kids
on demand or our webpage we're finishing
with something that you may have missed
in the sky the biggest meteor shower of
the year
the display is caused by earth colliding
with debris left behind by a comet that
passes every july in august
see you next time
[Music]